[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome to the latest episode of just
getting started here in the special
series of just getting started that we
uh began to
start dropping as the kids might say
once the nfl season began because it's
only the finest voices that the nfl has
to offer and a man who's called many
super bowls and calls only the biggest
games on the nfl on fox the pete roselle
award winner of 2020 from the pro
football hall of fame my good friend joe
buck how are you joseph
i'm good i'm good can you uh hear me on
this newfangled zoom thing i can indeed
hear you on this newfangled zoom thing
joe um i appreciate this are we still
doing this in 2021 like we got to do
this for the rest of our lives is this
what is this what we've become
well you know i mean i i'd have you over
you know i'd have you over yeah i feel
like you'd you'd do the same for me
again for sure you know yeah way back
come on yeah it's good it's good to be
on with a friend it's good to see you
you did a hell of a job i feel like
nobody ever
uh tells the emcee of events like that
either thank you or gives a round of
applause for the job you did so it was
great watching you you did a tremendous
job and that was a fun fun weekend in
canton and uh i'm glad to be on the
other side of it to be honest with you
and and pointed toward the regular
season well i mean this this show is
about origin stories and you having this
moment for you in your professional
career um leads in many different ways
to
an origin story about how you got
started the fact that you are
in the pro football hall of fame is a
rosella award winner
um
and there's uh there's there's a lot of
bucks on the wall man that's
what what what how does that land for
you i mean how does that actually sit
for you
well i mean it is weird if we are
talking origin stories to think of fox
getting the rights in 1994 which nobody
saw coming and and then david hill an
australian guy who's putting together
the stable of announcers and they buy
instant credibility with
madden and sumrall and stockton and
millen and then they wanted to give
younger guys a chance and it turned out
to be younger guys who had older guys in
their family tree that had done it for a
long time whether it's me with my dad or
brennaman with his dad or kenny albert
with his dad or kevin harland with his
dad i mean it was just it was a whole
run of a roster of people that
had been around it their whole lives but
had never really done it i mean i i was
standing there on opening day in 1994
in chicago getting ready for the bears
and the buccaneers having never done
not just the nfl but having never done
football in my life
uh and trying to fake my way through it
so yeah to get that award
under 30 years later is kind of
mind-blowing but uh still you know i've
worked hard between then and now and
uh you know i'm glad to share that wall
with my dad so um
wha what you you'd never called a
football game before
did anybody other than my close family
could hear yeah i never i never
i'd never done it i mean i you know i'd
done major league baseball at that point
for four years i did minor league
baseball for two years prior to that
i've done some other things i've done
horse jumping and college basketball and
all these other things but i've never
done football and so when fox
got the rights they sent a call out to a
bunch you know to agents and
uh to people to have their
clients
uh audition and and i went out there for
an audition based on
my mom giving my soon-to-be boss ed
goran's wife
patty my baseball tape and said i know
my son will be she said i know my son
will be good at football and so they i
think that got me in the door for the
audition and then i worked on calling
football with my dad in his living room
uh at spring training 1994 and i flew to
la
and i went into the studio and bob
stenner's talking to me in my headset
and i'm sitting next to tim green and we
call a game
off
a television monitor
and i knew it was going well but i
walked out of the
audition
and
george krieger who was one of the bosses
at the time at fox said you better get
an agent because we're gonna hire you
and i basically walk basically walked
out of there walked back to the air back
to the car back to the airport flew back
to florida for spring training knowing
that i just been hired by fox it was
kind of crazy no
kidding i mean it it's
it's wild joe that that's the way you
you got that gig and then so who was
your who was your first broadcast
partner the guy that i ended up
auditioning with tim green was my first
broadcast partner so i went
tim green
bill moss
brian baldinger
and then uh
kind of
i think that was it before madden and
sumrall went their separate ways and
madden went to another network and some
are all retired and they put me with
troy aikman with chris collinsworth and
the three of us filled in for them
starting in 2002. and so uh in between
all that obviously world series took
place what's your first memory
give me your first sports memory joe
i've always i don't think i've ever
first ever sports members yeah like
you've remember like like the ultimate
introduction you know i i i've never
asked you that i figured we're talking
origin stories this is a perfect
opportunity to ask you that being in the
back of the booth when i was maybe
three
at busch stadium four
but not at much older than that if i was
and sitting on the back ledge in the
radio booth
watching my dad and mike shannon and i
think bob starr at the time called the
cardinal game on radio
and i was excited and i moved my arm
real fast and i knocked a soda over on
top of my dad and mike shannon and bob
starr who were down there calling the
game and they turned around like
somebody just ran in the booth and threw
it at him but it was me
this little chubby kid who knocked soda
down on him and uh
i cried and i guess was not it wasn't
too traumatic of an experience because i
went back the next day and i basically
grew up in that booth so
any of my first any things
go back to the radio booth at busch
stadium old bush stadium
and uh that's the earliest one that i
can remember which leads to like lube
rock's 000th hit
and different things that happened in
cardinal history but but i think that's
the earliest that i can remember of
being a little kid and and making my dad
sticky is that
is so was this always something you
wanted to do because you saw your dad do
it you were exposed to it it's something
that you grew into wanting to do or you
just always knew this was it i i just
wanted to be him i wanted to be him
i wanted to i mean i wanted to play like
everybody you know a lot of my friends
did and then reality set in so
uh
i i just saw a guy who was
my
friend as much as he was my dad who took
me on road trip after road trip i was in
every national league city by the time i
was 12.
and uh
i saw a dad who went to work every day
and couldn't wait to get there
and i saw a guy who loved going to work
more than being off and so i think no
matter what he did
whether he was uh
you know a lawyer a policeman a plumber
a firefighter or a broadcaster an
astronaut or whatever it was going to be
that's what i wanted to do and it just
so happened that it was
sports announcer and uh i i paid
attention as a little kid
and
uh had a master's class of watching a
hall of famer do games
10 feet from me every night of the
summer so i think unless i was a
complete [ __ ] most of that was gonna
sink in and it did
and so um
i i i love every last part about this
joe and you know you and i again we've
known each other for a very long time
and i remember
seeing you call your first
world series on fox
um because i was a die-hard yankee fan
but i was also just new to sportscenter
like i got to sportscenter just as you
got into the booth for fox
for the world series and i just remember
what it was like for me to cover it
on sportscenter what was that like for
you to call that world series
in that first time yeah 96 i i think
that's another good first is being at
yankee stadium in the bronx and it's the
yankees return to greatness
um
it's jeter's rookie year it's tor joe
torrey who i grew up around
uh as a st louis cardinal he used to
play poker in
our basement with my dad when i was a
little kid yeah
and
and uh so there was there was a lot of
uh old home week stuff going on every
time i would call the yankee game
and to to be 27 and to carry that for
the network and be there
in the bronx and in atlanta and proclaim
the yankees as world champions it's
something i never thought i would do
um i as i said i wanted to be my dad and
to me in my mind my being my dad meant
being the cardinal announcer and
uh anything beyond that was stuff that i
never even thought of and my dad had two
years that were not
real good on the national
level doing games with tim mccarver in
90 and 91 and i saw kind of the nasty
side of the tougher side of network
broadcasting so for all the great
memories i had of growing up i saw a lot
of the bad stuff of being in the
national spotlight
and uh getting a chance to do that at a
young age you know every everything
happened way faster than i ever thought
it would or i'm sure my dad ever thought
it would i have mandated to ask what the
stakes were in that poker game
i you know i'm sure they weren't low uh
okay
yeah i mean it was a lot of a lot of
chips i was a little kid like
sitting on my dad's lap i probably sat
on joe torrey's lap and was throwing
chips around
but they were playing for
you know thousands of dollars i'm just
wondering so so you have maybe me you're
aware you have probably seen red shane
deans go all in is what you're basically
i've seen red shandings go all in
i've seen dan deardorff go go all in
i've seen uh
my dad i've seen tori i've seen
various other professional athletes go
all in uh during the course of my
childhood my very weird childhood it's
not oh come on it's it's it is um it is
truly amazing you know and it's
you know obviously you you've heard so
many stories about your father i'm sure
i i when before i took a job um my job
with sportscenter i i was i was flown
out to saint louis
to have um a meeting with a local
station i think it was kplr is that yeah
channel 11. sure yeah so i and i
remember i go into some like mahogany
walled office
that looked like something out of the
final scene of network
and it's this long table
and somebody who was i think the station
manager or owner wanted to meet me
and told me about what a type of
community st louis is
and the sports voices in saint louis and
basically told me
about jack buck and how he has been so
ingrained in the local community and
speaks at so many different events and
that this is the type of person i needed
to be if i was going to come to saint
louis
and my first thought was
i'm all in you know
absolutely i'm i i but it was
it was like the word of of
this station saying you will follow in
the footsteps of jack buck here in st
louis and i you know i
i obviously knew who your dad was but
i i can only imagine you growing up
around that and carrying that with you
every day yeah it was a lot i mean it
was definitely a lot and uh i don't
complain about it because it came with
so many positives
that we just talked about i mean growing
up in the atmosphere that i grew up in
you know that that's what prepared me to
do
what i did at an early age but but you
know the guy you're talking about his
name's ted koppler yeah and okay and i
remember that that's why it was kplr
coupler
um
and
and you think about the announcers that
that made their name in st louis it was
my dad it was harry carey it was bob
costas it was dan deardorff it was dan
kelly uh great hockey voice it was on
and on and on and on and and
a lot of it's centered around kmox radio
which is the flagship station of the
cardinals and then everybody would kind
of shoot off in their various directions
but
uh there is a there is a really strong
history of sports announcing in the city
and then when you have it not only in
your city but you have it in your house
and at your dinner table it it carries
with it a lot of
pressure a lot of good pressure but uh i
i've always and certainly back then but
i i've always felt the weight of that
carrying that forward and to this day
think about doing something that would
embarrass my dad almost as much as as
doing something that could embarrass me
and it's it's right there uh neck and
neck
well obviously it's all working good in
the hoods if you will and now here we
are what number season is this for you
now so i guess this would be 20 season
27 of you calling the nfl season 28 28
yeah
since 94 so getting up on 30 years i'm
signed one more year uh damn it i wish
it was i was wish it was two more years
and i could say hey i did 30 years and
it's been fun and
going on to the next chapter of my life
but i
i love it i mean i love going to work
and that's the best thing you know for
everything i said about my dad
i hope
and i think if you had my daughters on
natalie and trudy who are 25 and 21 not
my three-year-old boys
but the girls they would tell you that
they see the same thing in me like i'd
rather go do a game
than be off i'd rather
call a super bowl than watch a super
bowl i'd rather call a world series than
watch a world series i'd rather you know
that's a great feeling so
you know i i i'd like to think i carried
that forward too that i s i have this
love for doing what i do
and and if i ever did take it for
granted
um
i certainly don't anymore after the kind
of ups and downs that i've had
um you know with my health and with
different things that have gone on with
me so i
i have a complete joy in doing what i do
so i i literally can't wait for the
football season to start we have a lot
of games obviously with thursday sunday
yeah um but but i like it that way i'd
rather work than not so that's good well
and obviously that that there's that
time in october
where you are just going from one
event to the next of going to world
series games calling world series games
and then going to a thursday night and
calling more
world series games i i imagine that is
you in your element that's it that's it
like and and then you go from
one hall of famer uh in smoltz to
another hall of famer
in aikman and they're both so amazing at
what they do they make me smarter and
they call their shots it's like you know
smoltz is like watch out you know the
left fielder has a problem you know when
the ball's hitting the gap then the
ball's hitting the gap or aikman's like
well this match up top of the screen is
this could be an issue top of the screen
there's an issue i mean it really is
remarkable
calling of shots by the guys who sit
next to you and i love them like i love
them like brothers you know and that's
the best thing is that
i can lean on them
i can be
half in half out with both
all in with all of it but i am not there
every minute so i know that if i've been
gone
from troy and i walk in
and i do a thursday game and i've been
doing
monday tuesday wednesday baseball
he's ready to go he knows i'm ready to
go but i can lean on him a little bit
that week and then i come back to
baseball and either i'm tired or um
uh you know
leading into the game never in the game
but i if if i'm trying to just scramble
and get ready i can lean on john on the
baseball side um
so i think that that personal
relationship that i have with both guys
is what makes that whole month not only
work but fun
you know that that i i i
i don't try to dominate it i don't try
to i try to pick my spots i try to ride
the action and i try to go where it
feels like the game's taking us and then
i let them kind of shine
i tried to
and you're right i mean i think they're
so both well prepared that a lot of that
stuff is not by
luck it's
by preparation so i
i i really lean on them they know i'm
gonna be ready
and uh you know we just let it fly after
that and then you know your first world
series smoltz was in it the one that you
called
did you call any aikman games did you
get any count or or those were always
summer all madden contests at the
beginning of your i think i think that's
when troy knew his career
was over
because i was
i remember we showed up tim green and i
in let's say
96
yeah it had been like 96 or 97 yeah and
he came into the production meeting and
you can see the look on his face like
who in the hell
are these two guys
and
and tim was like hey so what's going on
and troy was like
yeah what's going on look do you have
any questions for me or uh you know
we're not gonna the small talk is not
gonna happen because he's used to
talking to madden and some role and
madden were
great friends by the end of all those
years of doing all those games so
yeah we did a game in cincinnati that
they had on halloween
i don't even know if it was as late as
96. i but but i mean they were world
champs you know in that little stretch
of time there and the last time they
went to the champ game was 95 so it i
don't think it was during that time i
but
yeah i joke all the time that when
troyec walked through the door and
looked into the production meeting room
is like okay this is over it's time to
go
and uh here we are doing games together
for this is our 20th year together that
was that was that was something that was
mentioned at the hall of fame that kind
of shocked me
that you that you're the longest paired
team of i i guess um
for the lack of a better phrase a game
um top of the flowchart
team
is that or second longest or
what that you've been playing i think
we're one year or one year of catching
uh madden and some raw i think it's in
there we're number two but i think in
this day and age to be anywhere near the
top of that with his
transient as some of these rights
holders situations are or
somebody gets a wild hair and they go
hey you know this guy stinks let's get
rid of him or this guy's just off the
field he's the hot new thing let's go
get him
to to have been together for 20 years
now the first three of them chris
collinsworth was part of that too
but uh a 20-year run like that is
in this day and age is something that i
know we're both very proud of and
neither one of us can believe it's been
that long because it feels like on one
hand it's been forever but on the other
it feels like it's just yesterday that
he came to my golf tournament and that
might have been the year you were there
but it was certainly early on and i was
i was leaning on him right out of the
gate like hey nice to meet you finally
after our production meeting but in a
different setting
and uh glad we're gonna be doing games
together we come to st louis to my
children's hospital event he's like i'll
i'll be there count on me which he's
just that kind of guy so i'm lucky that
way i'm lucky in every way that i get to
work with these two well isn't that the
name of your book right
the lucky bastard i i am both i'm both
lucky
well one thing before we uh we wrap this
up i want to pull on the strand of that
you you you left before did you say you
called horse jumping i did
yeah i've called horse jumping on bud
sports uh one of the bush
daughters the usch daughters
was big into uh horse jumping so i've
done horse jumping at the state
farm show arena in harrisburg
pennsylvania i've done it down in
florida i've done like yeah oxford jumps
and
double lockers and i mean it's just
basically
you talk about leaning on an analyst i i
had no idea what i was doing it's like
when i hosted uh
live bass fishing i mean it's just
crazy how little i knew and that i could
get through an hour an hour half of tv
just faking my way through well i mean
is that
you know
hate on other team
fishing is that where first bass fishing
is where you learn yes the other team's
horses the other team the other teams
fish uh
yeah yeah i always get accused of
rooting against everybody except in
those events because i think basically
nobody was watching
[Music]
bass fishing i mean that is hey man you
paid your dues there's no question about
all that well so there's nothing wrong
with that rich but it shouldn't be
live
there's the these these
this was live and somebody forgot to
tell the fish
that between 4 30 and 6 eastern that
they were supposed to bite on lures
because nobody caught anything it was
horrible and then we screwed up when the
when the
the final moment is leading into a
weigh-in of fish
you know you got you got a dog on your
hand so to speak and uh we screwed that
up too we did we had the wrong winner i
think i've never gone off the air with
like hey so the cowboys win and actually
it was the eagles no in this case i
think we got the wrong winner because we
got bad
weigh-in numbers so yeah
oh man i will close by asking you the
question i'm asking everybody here your
best piece of advice that you've gotten
in your career and from whom uh even if
it's not your dad i'm curious as to what
it would be or what where you might have
gotten it from yeah i thought of three
things the other day that my dad said to
me
and i'll try to remember him one
don't get on the umpires
because eventually you can disagree with
the call but let it go because people
get tired of hearing you complain about
umpires or referees two
um unless you think you could make the
play
ten times out of ten
don't
be hard on
who you're broadcasting for because it's
really hard and and you weren't good
enough and remember that and then three
broadcast the game like you know you
don't matter you're not nobody's if you
get hit by a bus walking in they're
still going to play the game and if you
go in thinking that people are tuning in
to listen to you you're going to be
going about it the wrong way so respect
the game and what you're covering and
and have fun with it
but short of that you know if you don't
show up somebody else will call it and
they'll still have a winner and a loser
i i
that middle part
that middle piece of advice about not
getting on like if you
unless you could make the play 10 times
out of 10
you should you know
pull pull your punch on making fun of
somebody
i i'll tell a quick story um that i wish
i had
known that
because when i first got to sportscenter
in 96 with my stand-up comedy background
everything was a joke everything was a
gag for me like
like nothing was to be taken seriously
and i was trying to entertain the entire
time
and i wanted to go on assignment and you
know i was a fort holder the entire time
as a matter of fact i remember
watching the world series with you
calling the game in october i just
gotten there in february and i'm a
die-hard yankee fan they hadn't been to
the world series since 1981 and i could
not believe i wasn't at the game
but i was understanding you know i had
my dream job and i remember watching you
go through the fox
celebrities who were at the game joe
and you got to kim fields the famed
tutti who i think was in a new show on
fox at the time
and i'm like i cannot believe tutti was
at the game and i was not
and um this is all coming into focus at
some point and i remember i finally got
to go on an assignment and i got to go
cover
um the seattle sonics a year later when
they were on that 60-win george carl
team and i remember walking into the
locker room and everyone looked nasty
from gary payton to george carl
sean camp they looked like they were
not happy to see anybody walk in the
locker room and i thought to myself did
i make fun of any of these guys on
sportscenter i took immediate stock
nervous that i'd screwed up because i
didn't get that piece of advice that
your dad gave you
and i i love that one
it's real because you know i think we're
all guilty of it
of treating b you start treating people
that way whether you're you've got the
microphone and and it's an embarrassing
moment if somebody doesn't come through
for their team and you know they're
trying their best to come through and if
they don't or they make a bone-headed
play or whatever it's not because
they weren't trying or they didn't care
and and i
you know i i think about that all the
time you know the way i get treated on
twitter the way you somebody will say
something to you it's almost like you
treat people like they are things and
you forget
that they have feelings and they have
that you know that stuff hurts and and
so if you're the one in the
up in the booth you know saying stuff
they don't really have any way of
getting back at you except to tell you
in private moment hey you were an
[ __ ] to me and and i just don't i
don't want that conversation i've never
had that conversation with anybody like
hey you were unfair when you said blank
and and that's a good thing because
man these guys are way better at this
than i'll ever understand and uh
it's not my job to rip them for
uh for a mistake it's just not
i remember i i was just looking around
that locker room going oh [ __ ] i did i
say anything about peyton what about you
know
uh george carl cause they were staring a
hole straight through me and i'm like
that's gotta be me but i think they just
you know were shocked by the celtics
that night anyway and it's just you know
it it stuck with me to this day i mean
that's like 24 years ago and i i thought
to myself when i go back on the show i
will not
do that anymore i will make sure that i
if i have to see anybody ever again
i will be able to hold my head up high
that i treated them fairly i will never
want to go through that again i'll never
forget that
to this day yeah it's a bad feeling and
actually i said i've never had that the
one guy the one guy that i that the
manning family was pissed at me for a
long time because they thought i was
unfair to eli and
i mean i get it i i get it i'm a proud
dad and i'm a proud brother and if
somebody was you know and and there were
games where eli didn't play well and and
if there are times where you have to say
you know that
he's having a bad game you know four
interceptions or whatever it is but but
i understand it and and i've had
confidence now they're all now we're all
great friends but i i had to go have the
conversation like look it's never been
personal
i've only tried to do my job and i
completely understand so let me have it
and and we can go from here and it's
been great ever since joe you're the man
thanks for taking the time i know your
crazy schedule uh best to michelle
beisner buck who we uh see on monday
nights on the worldwide leader and i
work with for a long time and
um sen send my best brother you're the
best thanks for doing this you too buddy
you too to your great family anytime
rich thanks that's the man joe buck
again i i've i met joe uh in the uh late
90s and um because we started pretty
much the same time i i mean when he when
he did the nfl on fox started there in
1994 i was just starting my tv career
in local tv at krcrtv the abc affiliate
in uh in northern california in uh
reading chico market
and uh then i got to sportscenter in 96
and i remember turning on and watching
the world series and seeing joe buck
and um and he's been doing baseball and
super bowls and
nfl ever since he he did his first super
bowl was nfl network's
second
super bowl uh he did the first super
bowl he did was
um new england
versus philadelphia in jacksonville
florida that was his first super bowl
that he called and that was the second
one that i did for nfl network our first
one was the year before in houston
between new england
and carolina when uh
when the patriots and brady won their
second
um and it was the second one they won
with vina terry winning it at the very
end
and um and then the next year they they
went back to back and that's the last
team to have gone back to back
to win a super bowl
new england and that was the first two
[Music]
super bowls nfl network ever covered and
the first one
on the back end of it is uh the first
super bowl that joe buck
has ever covered and then you could just
do every three years from there and now
here he is
getting set to have season 28
uh for him at fox
and just to
tell you a little bit more about what
happened i was in reading california
and um sent a tape to a headhunter
or three of them
actually just under the category of what
the hell right it's just first class
postage i'll make a tape i'll make a
recording of what i'm doing on the 11
o'clock sports the 5 o'clock sports
for the abc affiliate in redding
california this is i guess my origin
story in a way
and um
so
i i i did many of my broadcasts in
redding
in the bent of sportscenter i would do
sportscenter type highlights and
make pop culture references and use
voices and do whatever i thought was
entertaining
over high school highlights that i shot
on my own
well i mean the the company issued um
three-quarter inch camera which is this
huge ass camera you'd put it on your
right shoulder and this be less long
coaxial cable attached to this tape deck
that you'd have
um on your left shoulder with this big
strap and it was this huge contraption
and i would shoot the highlights myself
and i knew which
baskets were good or which football
plays were good and then i would use my
style on
on set
to put together a highlight
that looked and sounded like a
sportscenter highlight but it was just a
high school event
that uh i was i was broadcasting for
the affiliate that i was working for and
i put together a whole bunch of
interviews and a whole bunch of
of aspects of of of my sports casts
local sports casts and put together a
tape that looked and sounded like
sportscenter
because that's where i wanted to go
and i put a a tape together for a
headhunter
and sent it out and did it for another
headhunter and another headhunter there
were three in the united states at the
time that were very
you know popular amongst
top 30 markets and who knew at the time
espn they saw my tape
essentially
they saw my tape from krcr tv and i got
a call at work one day
um at my sports desk
and the way that the phones there worked
you got a phone call locally it would be
one long ring
if the phone was from outside of the
area code it would go ring ring ring
ring i've never had another phone like
that in my entire life
a round one
but the reason why i say this is it ring
ring when the ring ring would go it
would be like i think my parents calling
me from new jersey or my brother from
los angeles really nobody was calling me
from out of state out of area code
pretty much on my work line
and so ring ring it goes and it's
somebody
uh who says they're from the william
morris talent agency
said that their name was henry riesch
was his name
and he told me he was a an agent and he
had heard that i was one of the hot
up and coming sportscasters in america
oh like really that's what i thought to
myself my inner monologue is like you
got to be kidding me
because
i'm i'm not feeling very hot out here
and um
i've said okay and he said can you make
me
a tape can you send me your resume reel
right away
like absolutely i'll do that took his
name and his address and hung up the
phone and just started staring around to
see if
you know i was being punked
i think this even predated punk so it's
probably on candid camera to use the
phrase back in
1995 this was
and
i just picked up the phone and called my
brother in los angeles i'm like you
never guess what's gonna happen
i just got a call from william morris
and they want a tape
i'm like this is unbelievable
he's like that's unbelievable like great
hopefully something can come from i have
no idea hung up the phone
two minutes later
ring ring again
another outside call like this is
ridiculous there's no way
you know
this has happened before like okay did
my brother call my parents or whatever
and i thought to myself no no
i'm such hot [ __ ] that's espn on the
phone
and sure enough
i pick up the phone
and it's a guy named al jaffe
who was the headhunter
of
espn he was the talent
coordinator and finder
for espn i had sent him
unsolicited letters and resumes and
tapes for years
and it was
somebody saying al jaffe and i thought
for a split second this is my brother
telling one of my friends call him right
now and tell him it's al jaffe because
he knew i was sending
unsolicited tapes
go ahead pull his leg
and i almost carpet f-bombed the real al
jaffe to tell him you got to be kidding
me
but it was him to say
that he had just seen my tape and he
loved it
and he wanted to have an interview with
me
uh within three weeks down in los
angeles
when they were out in los angeles for
what at the time was
a an annual award show they don't have
it anymore called the cable ace awards
and he said he and a bunch of espn
executives are going to be there can i
make it down there
the problem is is that that was going to
be in november which is a sweeps month
for local television stations certainly
big at the time
where november and then another month in
the spring i think
i don't remember but i just remember
november was a big sweeps month so the
station was getting raided and asking
for a day off during a sweeps
month night
was
unheard of i mean like it had to be a
major family emergency on the spot to
ask for a day off and receive it
and i just remember i think i told my
my um
the sports director because i was the
number two there i think i just flat out
told him because i was close to them a
sweet man named mike mangus i think i
told him espn called me i gotta go i
gotta i gotta take this
meeting and i think he covered for me
that's part of the memory is hazy but i
remember flying down
to los angeles uh from reading taking a
prop plane from reading down to san
francisco and then from san francisco to
la and i remember being nervous because
that time of the year san francisco
could get fogged in quite a bit perfect
day landed in san francisco but i was
stuck in san francisco because there was
fog on the ground in los angeles of all
places and i didn't have a cell phone at
the time
i just didn't
this is 95 or
i remember borrowing someone's cell
phone on the plane to call the person
who was
in line to be my agent
and because i didn't have an agent i was
making like seven dollars an hour
and i remember calling that person up
and saying can you call al jaffe and
tell him i'm gonna be late
she did and they were understanding i
was going to be late i took a cab
straight from the airport to the hotel
on los cienega boulevard just south of
of um
[Music]
san vicente anybody who might know the
area where the beverly center currently
is in la that's where i met
al jaffe and one
executive after another came in and came
down and i did like this whole long
interview process took about two and a
half hours and then it was done and i
had no idea did they like me did they
not or what have you
and i
got a call a week later because i go
back up to reading
still doing my sportscasts wondering
have i just won the lottery did this
just happen i got a call saying they
wanted me to fly out to bristol now
and audition
in
the following
uh month in january
so i did that and i flew through chicago
and got all the way to chicago and um
and and
about a foot of snow fell in bristol
connecticut and
the northeast area and i made it as far
as chicago and how to turn around and go
back
and i remember just being so despondent
i'm like oh my god
i i made it as far as chicago i couldn't
get to espn will they never invite me
again is there is am i did i just blow
it is my opportunity over
and what's gonna happen
and um
i i flew back to
you know
a redding and
i remember going back there thinking
i i i just
spent weeks staring at the ceiling so
excited to get this opportunity to
audition at espn
and i couldn't even get there
sure enough 48 hours later we
rescheduled for the following week and i
flew back out there again
and at the same time my agent called me
and said that there's an opportunity
to be the number two sports anchor at
kplr in st louis
and you should go there too
and i'm like when i mean like i'm making
seven bucks an hour like i can't even
fly all around the country but i'm like
okay
you know i called my parents we you know
i got enough money to start paying for
flights all over the place espn paid for
the flight out i think i had to pay for
my flight out to
to st louis
and i went there and i tried out at st
louis
um
after i tried out at espn
and the reason why i'm i'm setting all
that up and i'll tell an espn my story
in future episodes about my tryout at
espn that was wild
but i tried out espn and went back and
went to st louis
and i remember going to st louis you
know and i had to try my hardest because
who knows if espn's gonna happen but i
didn't want the gig in st louis if i was
gonna get a gig at espn
and i i tried st louis and i had that
try out and i had that sit down in that
mahogany room where
the guy who joe bucks just told me he
knew that the guy was who owned the
station and why is the call letters is
his last name and his name even escapes
me now after joe just told it to me my
god
but i i remember sitting at this table
and listening this guy like
sort of
lecture me in a way about jack buck and
i'm like
thinking to myself
how the hell am i going to live up to
jack buck's legacy i don't even know i
mean that's jack friggin buck
in st louis i'm like
sure i'll try you know if i'm going to
come to this community i mean i just
you know as a new york jewish kid flew
all the way up to redding california to
work and i became part of that community
even though it was like living in
northern exposure if you remember that
tv show about the jewish doctor in
alaska like it was the jewish
sportscaster in
redding california and i i kind of
wanted to tell them like hey man like
i'm i'm all in like i just went
fly fishing and panning for gold and
redding you know like i get into the
community wherever i go
by the way that's what i did i never fly
fish before and i certainly didn't pan
for gold and the place where i grew the
biggest mountains were made of trash you
know where i grew up from and
that beautiful community in reading i
was all in on it
so i told him what i i thought he wanted
to hear without deep down thinking uh
how am i gonna work for this guy if he's
telling you gonna live up to jack buck's
legacy you wanna talk about pressure i
mean i'll put the pressure on myself but
i mean
i just kind of felt a little
uncomfortable leaving that
that mahogany office room and i remember
getting on a pay phone
before boarding the flight back to
reading to call my agent to say did you
hear from espn and the answer was yes
they offered me a five-year contract
and i'm like holy [ __ ] this is happening
and i got back on the
flight and you know
um
i i i'm like
fax me the paperwork
i will sign on the dotted line i sign in
the dotted line i get my two weeks
and um you know i left and
you know valentine's day of 2 of
1996 and started working at espn a week
later
and my first sports center was march
madness of of uh of 1996.
and this all comes back to me right now
talking about st louis and talking to
joe and
the
son of jack buck and just thinking the
pressure i felt
at the invoking of his name
and that's what i love about joe and
that's why i always and the fact that i
use the word defend him
it's you know
ridiculous he's in
uh um now a hall of fame nfl pro
football hall of fame broadcaster
and you know whatever
broadcasting wing there is for baseball
he'll be in there too and deserves it
and i love listening and call a game and
i don't understand why he's at all
viewed by people as
provocative or
polarizing i think that's
patently unfair and
i wanted to use at least this piece of
real estate to say it
that'll wrap it up for this edition of
just getting started our special
uh edition
of just getting started shows involving
voices of the nfl rolls on next week
[Music]